Hola buenas noches la Unión Europea ha
aprobado un nuevo paquete de sanciones
se trata ya del Nobel del noveno tan
solo una semana después de que la
comisión europea lo propusiera la en
este nuevo paquete de sanciones se
incluye la prohibición de exportar
drones a Rusia pero tampoco se podrá
exportar a terceros países como Irán
para evitar que drones de fabricación
europea acaben atacando a Ucrania el
nuevo paquete También incluye algunas
excepciones Como por ejemplo la
posibilidad de pagar a individuos o
empresas previamente sancionados por la
Unión Europea pero que permiten el
transporte de fertilizantes y de
alimentos solo en estos casos será
permitido a pesar de las reticencias de
Polonia y Ucrania que querían más dureza
algunos países encabezados entre ellos
por España estaban pidiendo esta
posibilidad para evitar una mayor
hambruna especialmente en países en
desarrollo y del continente africano en
estas nuevas sanciones también se
incluye a 200 nuevos individuos en la
lista de sancionados en total ya son más
de 1.500 por lo tanto va engrosándose
poco a poco la lista en esta nueva lista
de sancionados también se incluyen las
fuerzas armadas rusas las sanciones
esperan que puedan entrar en vigor en
las próximas horas bueno Esther qué más
se ha aprobado hasta ahora en la reunión
de líderes europeos
sí la reunión está a punto de terminar
los líderes europeos han tenido la
economía como uno de los platos fuertes
de esta reunión entre ellos está la
energía te lleva meses hablando sobre
los altos precios de la energía en la
Unión Europea Pues bien los líderes
europeos han urgido a los ministros de
energía que se reúnen el próximo lunes a
intentar poder poner un límite al precio
del gas llevan semanas en discutiendo de
hecho esta misma semana fracasó una
nueva reunión los líderes europeos han
pedido que esta vez sí hay que avanzar
lo suficiente también se ha podido
hablar también de las relaciones trans
atlánticas entre Estados Unidos y la
Unión Europea especialmente de la ley de
la reducción de la inflación que tiene
las reacciones transatlánticas muy
tensionadas